we're officially less than a month away
from the start of school
right now many families are checking off
their to-do list including getting
back-to-school vaccinations kate houston
went to a clinic
in the southwest valley where families
can also get a covet 19 vaccine
as families head out to get back to
school supplies health officials are
also urging them to take care of back to
school vaccinations
pediatricians say it's okay to get
mandatory shots with the kovid 19
vaccine
at the same time on august 9 clark
county school district
students will head back to class kids
going into kindergarten and seventh
grade will need to get certain
vaccinations ahead of time the southern
nevada health district is offering many
of these required shots as well as the
covid 19 vaccine
to students 12 and older at various
schools through mid-august
melanie lee and her dad stopped by fess
middle school in the southwest valley to
get her covid 19 vaccine
it's about time that we all move on and
i just want
us all to get back to a normal life and
have her because she started high school
although the time frame has passed for
students to be fully immunized against
covet 19 by the time school starts
dr michael tenby with centennial
pediatrics says getting it now can still
offer some defense against the virus
even if you get a first dose and start
school and then get the second dose
you'll have some protection going right
into school
and the earlier you start the earlier
you're fully immunized
and can feel comfortable being in a
school environment without a mask dr
tembi says getting the kovid 19 vaccine
ahead of school starting
can also prevent kids from missing class
if they have a mild reaction and need to
stay home
kate houston 8 news now